hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of day one between vladislav
artemis
this is game four and uh now artemiev is
in a must-win situation in order to tie
the first match because levon
won the previous game as you've seen now
really a crazy one
if you haven't do check it out i will
put a link to it in the description
below just a really really
uh crazy 25 move game uh
artemis just uh well he he didn't think
much of the attack and then it just
happened and
that was it but here now artemi will get
a chance with the white pieces to bounce
back and let's see what happens because
this one
uh is uh well i would say just this
short but it's not but it kind of is but
you'll see what i mean
so artemis with the white pieces opens
with d3 we have knight to f6
and now bishop to g5 he goes for the
trompovsky attack
uh we have d5 knight to d2 and now
c5 of course striking in the center we
have e3
and now c captures on d4 we have e
captures and the bishop to g4 now
attacking artemis queen
we have knight to f3 defending while
developing with e6 and
now uh there is one game in the database
where c3 was played but here we have
h3 and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so here the bishop is challenged or what
you do you could go back with bishop to
f5 bishop to h5 but uh here eleven
decides to trade we have characters
captures
and just bishop to d6 a nicely
continuing development and he's saying
i'm not really worried about this this
is this is nothing
so bishop to d3 and now knight to c6
with c3 defending the d4 pawn and
queen to c7 now levon saying i might
castle kingside but i also might castle
queenside depending on what you do
so here uh artemis castled kingside and
we have
castles queen side by lavon and now of
course black will try to attack on the
kings side whereas artemia will try to
attack on the queen side so who will be
faster here
it's definitely the kind of position
artemia would want since he needs a win
here
but it's uh well a very doubled edge
position as you'll see we rook the c1
now always a useful move aligning the
rook with the queen and the king that
are on the same file solar one has to
sidestep this uh we have king to b8 and
now
b4 now preparing a pawn storm here on
the queen side
we have h6 black does the same so now
you don't want to go bishop to h4 and
allow g5 with tempo so bishop
way all the way back to the e3 and
g5 now g4 is coming as you have a nice
support for this with your knight and
now
b5 attacking the knight here knights the
a5
and now knight to d2 taking care of
these squares and later on you might
play queen a for c4 and so on trying to
make a breakthrough here
uh and then now levon plays knight to c4
which is very interesting because like i
said these are castles on opposite sides
you want to play g4 you want to bust
open the position
uh you know much quicker than your
opponent can do the same on the queen
side but he says nope there's no rush
i'm going to play knight to c4 first uh
trade off a pair of knights here
or rather trade off a pair of pieces
because white captures with the bishop
so bishop captures d
captures and now queen to a4 now uh uh
preparing a very nasty trick here he
wants to push d5 and then
we'll do some damage here so rook the c8
level not worried about this he just
adds another defender to the pawn here
and d5 now threatening checkmate with
queen captures on a7
uh and now comes b6 you have to defend
against this we have d
captures on e6 now f captures and now
knight to f3 and the white's position
here is not
pretty you don't have a good way of
continuing the attack you
in order to make some sort of a
breakthrough on the queen side you need
to move your queen then push the a pawn
all the way and
that takes a lot of moves so here he
goes knight to f3 he wants to play
knight to d4 and then bring the knight
over to
c6 if he can do this without damaging
his position
too much then could be great for him but
levon now doesn't miss the opportunity
he advances the pawn to g4
we have h captures knight captures and
not knight to d4 going after this c6
square
but here uh well we've just reached the
position from the thumbnail
i'm just gonna prepare this uh feel free
to pause the video and try to find a
crushing win here for lavon while i give
you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it uh congratulations on spotting that
there are some checkmating patterns here
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to h2
with check it's important to bring the
king to h1 first and now only now after
the king moves to h1
uh we are going to well play either
queen to e5 or queen to f7 it doesn't
really matter because we just want to
get our queen to h5 and
we can do this both via the f7 and the
e5 square so let's say queen to f7
and there's really no defense here
whatever white does you're going to play
queen to h5 and there's no defense there
there is nothing you can play here uh it
it's completely
uh the same whatever you play here if
you go knight to c6 check we can even
capture it doesn't matter and if pawn
captures queen to h5 and that's it
there's no defense bishop g1 bishop f4
g3 bishop anywhere just delivers
checkmate
so this was in the position but like i
said artemia was very low on time he was
already down to three minutes and maybe
levon
uh figured out okay artemis calculated
that this doesn't work he spent a lot of
time
and it's maybe maybe not all that simple
to spot this queen maneuver that you
have to bring the queen to h5 but okay
uh levon played rook h2f8 instead he
brought another attacker into the game
and now knight the c6 with check but
it's okay lemon says my king is
perfectly fine on a8
we have queen captures and c4 but now
the problem is the same idea doesn't
work levon does go bishop h to check
king h1
but now you don't have queen uh queen
here okay you can't play queen here
because of the knight but queen f7 uh
loses the queen captures on uh g4 which
was impossible as the
uh black pawn was still on c4 but now
that white captured it
uh it no longer works so here levon
plays bishop to g1
now threatens queen to h2 checkmate and
uh
he doesn't even have to look for a win
here he he only needs a draw and he's
the winner of the first match
so g3 stopping checkmate but now knight
captures an e3
and you can't grab this knight because
if you do then queen captures on g3 and
checkmate is coming if you capture the
bishop then this is checkmate and
there's not much you can do here
so instead after knight captures on e3
queen the e4 was played now threatening
a lot of nasty discoveries here
but levon says nope that that simply
will not do
i'm just going to capture your rook so
knight captures on f1 and i might even
use this for a thumbnail i mean it's uh
it's also a
really nice one uh so yeah after knight
captures on f1
we have knight to d8 check and there are
a lot of possible discoveries but you
want to make sure you do the right one
so here we have knight the d8 check uh
and now you
you can't really do all that much you
can't block because the knight and the
queen cover the g7 square
so you have to play this and now artemis
just repeats knight to c6 we have king
to a8
but like we said uh a draw is enough for
levon to win the first match so artemiev
has to play on
so rook captures on f1 but now just
bishop captures on f2
and now if you continue uh past this
point without
going for the perpetual you're just
going to lose the game so here artemia
was forced to go into a perpetual 98
check
king b8 knight c6 jerking the eight
knights the a5 check now
is the same king to eight knight to c6
check king to a8 and he was in this
position on move 35
uh that artemis and arunian uh agreed to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here for white at least because he
has to repeat this in order not to lose
the game
black would be very happy to get a movie
uh but yeah
uh that's the the first uh first match
we were able to cover uh
most of the games well three or three
out of four and i've shown what happened
in game one so that's um
pretty much all that there that happened
uh artemia had an amazing chance in game
two and he
he kept on pushing pushing pushing but
levon somehow survived
uh as you've seen you know whenever you
ha if you still have a night you have a
chance that's how it goes
uh and then you know in game three he
just obliterated artemia event now in
game four
uh well uh artemia tried but it simply
wasn't enough uh by creating an attack
you also allowed black to create an
attack
and uh it's interesting that levon
missed that beautiful beautiful sequence
but this one definitely a position to
show your friends at the bar in the
library
because the queen maneuver is something
maybe to remember
that could be used you know in your own
games in the future
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank lane
sassan
connor clark james walker peter milner
and wolfgang schmidt for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with
the other match of the semi-finals oh
the finals uh
or rather the battle for the third place
between magnus and ding
uh and uh well tomorrow we continue with
the second
day of the finals so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your weekend
[Music]